hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Alex
Robinson
Alex Robinson from the real mr. Robinson
channel is here today we're gonna check
out the Steve Jobs official trailer
number one michael fassbender as Steve
Jobs
so how come ten times in a day I read
Steve Jobs as a genius what do you do
musicians play their instruments I play
the orchestra don't like his voice here
we've been worse than usual this morning
I didn't think that was possible
it's a system error fix it fix it yeah
we're not a pit crew at Daytona this
can't be fixed in seconds didn't have
seconds you had three weeks the universe
was created in the third at that time
well something you'll have to tell us
how you did it will to manage
expectations out there you see oh this
reminds you of a friendly face it's warm
and it's playful and inviting and it
needs to say hello if you keep
alienating people for no reason there'll
be no one like for it to say hello sue
your Apple stock was worth 441 million
dollars while your daughter and her
mother aren't welfare you must be able
to say that she looks like [ __ ] you're
issuing contradictory instructions
you're in support they make people
miserable if that weren't true doesn't
sound that diabolical to me we've spoken
to the fire marshal in the building
manager they're gonna come in and tell
everyone to leave if the fire causes a
stampede to the unmarked exits it'll
have been well worth it for those who
survived the board please you're no
longer necessary to this company
I sent the garage and invented the
future because artists lead and hacks
ask for show of hands
you're gonna anything are you you're
being ridiculous
I'm gonna sit center court won't you do
it yourself make everything all right
Felicia fix it
Steve Jobs it was a big build-up to a
underwhelming title oh man you know what
I I like what I'm seeing so far to be
honest there seems to be an energy about
it I'm hoping that's just a trailer but
Aaron Sorkin scripts tend to be very
snappy yeah and I could feel that level
of snappiness in there the dialogue
seems really well done and Michael
Fassbender this is obviously gonna be
the Oscar consideration performance
possibly you know like there was that
Ashton Kutcher portrayal that came out a
while ago and there are some people in
reading online who are like wood and
other Steve Jobs movie I'm like we need
another Steve Jobs movie to be done
properly
did you see the Ashton Kutcher yeah
exactly I'm looking forward to it they
got a great cast assembled here yeah I
know like the basic outline of Steve
Jobs life I'm not too familiar with the
details I heard he was an [ __ ] to
work with I like that they're not
sugarcoating that in this it doesn't
seem to be a cliche biographical picture
it seems like they're really focus on a
specific time at least yeah and not just
like half of it is going through his
entire life yeah I have Ashley and then
the other half is a Apple product
placement yeah cuz a lot of the time
these bio pics try to cover so much yeah
well that's what the Ashley Kutcher one
did and like Michael Fassbender hereit's
I still hear his voice like there's
nothing like really transforming to
Steve Jobs but I've seen a lot of actors
take on real people and they come across
as really good even though they don't
look or sound like that actual person
yeah yeah
Ashley Kutcher watching that movie made
me like man this guy's such a dick
anyway but yeah when Steve Jobs movie it
looks it looks solid the cinematography
looks great Danny Boyle knows how to
provide energy with his films too
everything about it seems like it's
gonna be working out well like it I
trust the crew behind it and I trust the
cast assembled so with everyone's track
record involved something tells me this
is gonna be a solid picture you know I I
heard Aaron Sorkin wrote it in like
there's three it's it's only takes place
over three scenes or three events or
something I don't know Danny Boyle had
him change it when Danny
Serco Rick as that was originally when
they're talking with david fincher about
it yeah because it looks because it
mainly looks like it only takes place at
like three specific times in his life
but i like that rather rather than
trying to cover like a montage of all
this stuff that are looking for the most
impactful moments of his career and how
he went about it how he was during that
time so yeah also looks like they're
covering what the first movie did except
they'll probably do it a lot better
they won't gloss over it you know what
even if this movie's bad even if ends up
being a disappointment it can't be worse
than the Ashton Kutcher one yes but if
it did kudos to them because that's a
hard task to do that is anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to it you know you you new
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out the real mr. Robinson
channel does movie reviews on there
check it out we just did a spoiler
review for Terminator Genisys so check
that out too you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine if
he's not on vine but I'm on vine forget
his life so oh I'm sorry I shouldn't be
so mean if you were a girl like
complement you I'm friend be a bro you
know we bag on each other because we got
dicks
Kurt Chavez Ryan I'm a huge fan of the
reactors especially you in the big four
I will be leaving for the Philippines in
the next three days so please give me a
shout out it's it's nine days after this
request sorry man oh because I'll
probably forget about you tell time
around I said how I love you guys I'm a
huge sports guy by the way just let you
know that's great man Kurt Chavez I'm
half Filipino I don't know if you know
that you know that means medium-sized
penis that's what it comes with
that's a territory Kirk shabbos me feel
better by myself dude let's see what you
look like uh yeah you're clearly
Filipino you know what this means right
I know everything about you already you
like karaoke you're a huge Manny
Pacquiao fan and you have high
cholesterol yeah definitely looks like
that he looks like the kind of kid who
has high cholesterol anywho I'm sorry